[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster college today I'll be talking
about the Larsen super loop coaster and
showing you how to build one although
just a quick note you might also know it
by its in-game name the halogen ring and
also before I'm actually going to show
you how to build this coaster I want to
spend quite a few minutes just
explaining some background information
behind this coaster and all sorts of
useless information about the theme park
industry that you probably didn't want
to have in the first place and maybe
you're just here for a beginner tutorial
about planet coaster but you know I'm
just going to give you all of this
information anyway so about the Larsen
super loop coaster it's one of the most
interesting coasters in the world I
think it's very popular among theme park
enthusiasts and roller coaster
enthusiasts because it does a lot of
loop-de-loops and generally there are
many different factors in roller
coasters that you know theme park and
roller coaster enthusiasts sector into
their enjoyment of the rides and of a
park but really the amount of times that
a coaster goes upside down is generally
considered to be the best measure of how
good a roller coaster is and so when
you'll find somebody standing in a queue
of a roller coaster and they're really
boasting about how many loop-de-loops
that coaster has chances are that they
are a theme park enthusiast or a roller
coaster enthusiasts because that is what
these people are really into now you'll
have some of the general public kind of
sing some stuff about airtime things
like that that isn't really too
important it's all about how many times
you go upside down and going upside down
is something that the Larsen super loop
also known as the fireball nowadays
though many people just call it the
Larsen looper because there's
alliteration in that name I suppose but
that ride does it quite a bit and
because of that it is very often seen as
one of the most popular rides in the
world in fact when there was still the
Mitch hawkers pole which wasn't really a
good pole for measuring how good roller
coasters were the Larsen looper didn't
really get anywhere but now we have the
golden ticket Awards which is a great
way to measure how good parks are and
how good
courses are and almost every year the
Larsen super loop coaster is number one
on the ticket poll so yeah I think it's
pretty certain to say that this is among
the best roller coasters in the world
and very very much liked by roller
coaster enthusiasts especially one of
the other reasons by the way why that is
so is because credits play a very large
role in roller coaster enthusiasts
communities you might have heard of
these credits or something that you'd
get on every roller coaster that you
ride and it's kind of like the the
roller coaster enthusiasts with the
highest amount of credits it is kind of
like the best roller coaster enthusiasts
if that is a way to put it so they're
all kind of like fighting for the amount
of credits now the amount of credits
that you get per ride kind of depends on
how good that ride is like what is the
reputation of that ride are you going to
ride a B and M like say this is
something like crackin at SeaWorld
that's only worth about three credits
because it really isn't that interesting
but say you're going to ride if a coma
LLC which is upside down and actually
has multiple loop-de-loops as well
that's going to be worth like 20 credits
and so you'll see that roller coaster
enthusiasts want to ride the rides to
give them all of these credits and this
is also one of the reasons why these
license super loops are so popular
because it gives you one credit but
every time you go upside down and they
go upside down about 30 times so that's
30 credits per license super looper and
let's find a really the best way to gain
credits anyway that was the story behind
the ride I think it's about time that we
start actually and what was it did I
yeah did I talk yet about the fact that
is very popular among six legs parks now
six Mike sparks you might know are some
of the there's some of the up cool that
they're some of the there's some of the
parks that are very very like not so
well themed per se but theming isn't too
necessary it's more about you know how
thrilling is the park the really one of
the one of the parks let that focus on
those bare thrills which is why there
really some of the most popular parks
and some of the most well respected park
out there and especially recently six
Lex parks have been buying a lot of
these licensed super lube coasters and
so many of them have been at this point
that they're really like increasing
their coaster counts by quite a lot with
all of these super loops which is one of
the reasons why they're really seeing as
the park to go to if you want to run a
roller coaster anyway that was just some
more information about some theme parks
I think it's really time to get into
building the Larsen super loop or know
the license fireball or the Larsen
looper or as it's called in game the
hellion ring I think it's time to
finally built this thing and actually
show you how to build a good layouts for
a lot in super looper and also show you
how you can you know actually get this
thing in in a nice way
maybe set it up with some sight lines
kind of presented as the main icon of
attraction in whatever area you're
building it in so that your your going
to be able to make sure that the entire
area kind of works with the placement of
the right as well that the composition
is right so yeah with all of that in
mind and with all of the things that I
just told you about this coaster I think
it's yes it's pretty good time to start
building this ride so yeah one thing
that you do want to pay attention to
with this ride is that you want to make
sure that you can actually find it so if
you're going to go to click on right
over here you can actually find the
hellion ring right here and be careful
not to click on any of these other rides
by the way that'll make sure that you
are not going to place the light in
super loop so you really have to click
on this icon right here so you have to
hover your mouse over it and then click
the left mouse button if I'm correct
yeah that should be it and click that
mouse button
and there we go and that is pretty much
our entire layouts for the Larsen super
lube done now you just want to be very
careful with how you place this thing
again it really has a huge impact on the
entire surroundings and you can kind of
tell already that it really changes the
the general appearance of the area
around it and I always find that really
important like what are your sight lines
how does the entire area come together
how does ending this ride help the
composition of this area to be more
strong and to really draw your attention
toward this loss and looper and you can
see it's really working right now like
when you look at this your attention
straight going to the larson looper so
that's that's really good already and I
think we can even raise this thing up
maybe a little bit let's see something
like that should be pretty good I'm not
entirely sure why exactly I'm talking
about the height that you should be
raising the ride but you know I like to
talk a bit more about some useless
details that you might not want to hear
about in the first place but you know
who has time to make beginner tutorials
when you can just go into the import
knowledge way too deeply so yeah I think
it's time to start placing the ride
something like that should work there we
go and now let's test the ride and see
if it's actually going to make the
layout I'm not quite sure if it's
actually fast enough to make this hill
on the top here since it's quite high so
let's see it's getting there slowly but
surely and I think we're almost going to
make it on almost the next round
not quite ere we go so now it's doing
all of the loop-de-loops there we go
that was about 30 in one direction and
then 13 the other direction as well
which is really great and yeah that's
basically this ride now I think it's
very important to test it as well so I'm
just going to very quickly place some
simple paths and trees and I'll be back
with you in a second
so this is what the right looks like and
it's finished today and I'm quite
happier with it
I think there could still be some slight
changes to it like some other elements
maybe a combination of two different
elements something like that might be
fun to mess around with but generally I
am really happy with how the ride so now
I think the most important thing of
course is getting that layout right
obviously I kind of skipped the part
where I place the three is in the parts
but the crucial elements of the coast of
course is getting the layout right for
some reason
realism is really important to me and I
like to talk about these courses as if I
was building an actual coaster like
based on the way the actual
manufacturers make them not entirely
sure why because it just kind of seems a
little bit ridiculous anyway but you
know it doesn't really matter it gives
the end results I think looks quite good
as you can tell by this thing right here
and yeah that is basically all I wanted
to say for this episode of planet
coaster college I hope you that was my
pen sorry about that but I hope you
enjoy this episode I definitely hope you
learned something from it as well not
just how you can build this coaster in
planet coaster which might have been
what you were coming from but maybe also
what this course actually is and why
it's so great and part of why theme
parks are so amazing why roller coasters
are so fascinating the way everything
works
I'm not beginning a little bit through
series there yeah so yeah I hope you
enjoyed this and learn something from it
stay tuned for the next planet coaster
college where if I remember correctly
we're going to work on the genie roller
coaster right here which is also a
really amazing roller coaster it's very
popular around the planet and while it
doesn't go upside down it does spin a
lot so that's kind of like going upside
down but then sideways anyway thank you
guys for watching again I hope you
enjoyed I hope you learned something
from this
remember to know I'm not going to say
that I'm I hope you enjoyed and I'll see
you later guys
peace